I'll IMDB right now and you know how
they have new trailers come up on the
homepage yeah yeah there's one I haven't
seen the trailer but it says a rubber
meet Robert a little tire with big
dreams and a deadly secret and there's a
picture of a tire it says yeah that's
exactly the movie is called a rubber and
it says meet Robert a little tire with
big dreams and a deadly secret okay
I like is it really a horror movie about
a tire I don't know I've ever seen a
bunny
do you ever see flubber have a different
I'm on the homepage right now of the
movie and it says when Robert and
Anatomy tire discovers his destructive
telepathic powers he soon sets his
sights on a desert town in particular a
mysterious woman who becomes his
obsession you've got to be kidding me
so it is a movie about a tire is it
directly but um
David Fincher Quentin Dhupia Terry like
Quentin Tarantino Depew I don't it might
be a foreign so I'm not really sure I
guess by the last name you could say it
is I don't really recognize anybody in
the cast it might be a foreign film shut
up okay it's a foreign film it's not
texting me random person I like your
ringer that was an accurate
that actually upset that they're texting
me that's funny
okay ah you like LA Confidential right I
just bought that and watched it it's
amazing
that's what their moves that that is a
good movie boy that movie desert Oh
better than mr. Brooks yes LA
Confidential
is better than mr. Brooks in my opinion
they're not in any way similar this is
true but it's still a better movie in my
opinion like that is a legitimate movie
like I as soon as like the main story of
that film started the main detective
case I was completely engrossed in
everything and it was so well directed I
don't know what happened to Curtis
Hanson like he made a few really good
movies he made that and he made I liked
in her shoes I can't remember what are
you laughing at me
yes funny I can't remember what the
other one was but yeah then all of a
sudden he made that movie the lucky you
with Eric Bana hey that wasn't a bad
movie that was a pretty good movie no it
wasn't it was I liked the stuff between
Eric Bana and Robert Duvall and I liked
reporter teens the stuff with Drew
Barrymore know with that stuff with has
a self main story man shut up so it was
good sorry to Jeremy Jones that look
like Eric Bana but I don't really see it
dude everyone thinks you look like a
different actor that you don't look like
I understand the Tom Cruise one you
don't look like sent were thinking Sam
were they good
oh just tell you you look like Christian
Bale - no that's Tom no Tom doesn't look
like Christian Bale I can see it in the
one picture he made himself comparing
himself to Christian metal but oh he
made wonder voice which I loved
that's all my Netflix queue imma watch -
yo oh my gosh that's a great movie he
made eight mile with Eminem and there
was the river wild what that movie where
they're on the river
laughs meryl streep takes on a pair of
armed killers while navigating a
spectacularly violent River yes exactly
exciting a hand that rocks the cradle I
love LA Confidential like made him why
is he doing a TV movie now do you think
Cameron Diaz is hot she can be um in the
movie uh what happens in Vegas I
remember she was really really really
hot but there are other movies I don't
find her attractive at all I think it's
hilarious how in the Green Hornet
did you see yeah by the way yeah review
for enough my bed you know that's my
videos anymore yes I do
oh yeah I remember you commented on that
video they had counted on it cuz I'm
great stuck me not remembering things I
don't know yeah sorry yeah anyway she
like her smile is so famous
you know she shows up in the first shot
it zooms in on her face she just kind of
looks around gets this huge dorky smile
for no reason
it's like Roger Ebert said in his
reviews he said it was like she smiled
just to get it out of the way because it
was like in her contract you must smile
at least once in this film which is like
okay perish there I did it in the first
shot
it's hilarious I didn't like that movie
I'm sorry that was Roger Ebert gave it
one star apparently someone told me that
yeah I would give it two out of four it
was fun man it had fun for it yeah but I
mean I just I didn't I mean I felt like
a toe was the main superhero I mean he
did everything well no well that plays a
part of the movie it does but I don't
know I think it was way too long that's
for sure
did you at least like the old ling-su
actually yes I loved the opening scene
and I wish the rest of it was like that
where James Franco and everything
spoiler by the way I already said it but
um I said it a buyer even people who
don't spoil it I'm like shut up
did spoil it for me I didn't know in
Tucson that the two barrel gun sake I
have a gun with two barrels in fact I'll
bet you bet James Franco totally
reminded me of Tom chattel - and that
opening thing why because of the goatee
you had a goatee and he's like I own a
club I am the greatest
are we talking we're going to talk about
crap we're talking crap about channel
bed oh it's very likely gonna watch no
Tom Schaad oh crap no Tom chattel
crabbing yeah and something tells me
he's not gonna watch this unless
somebody's like hey Tom that talked
about you and that thing yeah you know
that will happen I know because time of
the video there's some crab but the grid
is YouTube critic ever shadow bash the
crap out of them who are your favorite
YouTube movie critics well when I when I
started making her views in like October
of 7 or whatever there was like no one
except mr. black so I always oh like a
dead to him I would say although he
doesn't really make videos anymore mr.
black yeah oh he used to like back in oh
seven used to make like videos all the
time and like it was like the only big
YouTube movie creator like everyone
liked it me just like stopped by like
summer away maybe I don't know Missy I
started and summer oh wait you started
some ro9 no really dude your first
review was Tanya oh yeah my bad I'm a
year early without a bid tonight well
it's kind of 3 a.m. over here seriously
yeah it's 244 I bet your one hour ahead
of me oh oh it's not an hour ahead of
you oh that sound like it was three like
3 3 - it's 1 2 42 ok so here's their
black that's it here's a nigger of use
anymore well Steve like no I was just
saying okay I'll always really like him
it's old videos are still
you want to educate yourself throw um
but I like spill their videos are really
funny
probably more humor than cinematic
insight I would say definitely but I
like right now in terms of you know the
other category I probably said Jeremy
Jones yeah yeah he's my favorite you
stop yeah Gavin dad I like them they're
funny she's really nice and his her
dad's hilarious
oh I'm sorry big bad like them you know
what he picked for his top for his worst
movie of 2010 he picked transformers 2
that came out in 2009 he hates that is
that how much he is he hates it so much
he named it as the worst movie of the
following year also is that great that's
hilarious he's like 65 years old nice
it's like I hate transformers to Jeremy
Jeremy with the heck Jerry Maguire came
in from that folks other day Oh have you
ever seen it no I haven't I watched some
of it already I think it's alright yeah
it gets better as it goes on sure hope
so I just don't like Jay Mohr like I
never have
I've never seen him in one performance I
was like hey Jay Mohr you're pretty
awesome like I don't know you look good
this is always like that random casting
choice I'm like outside yeah I know
you're always just like why did they
choose Jay Paul did you see here after
ah yeah trying to make Phineas would I
was like fine Jay Mohr in his movie like
yeah he was my two scenes I know he's in
small soldiers for goodness sakes yeah
so oh so like I was laughing like
completely forgot about that movie when
I
Jay Mohr I don't think of a movie star
I'm like hey that's that guy that works
at the gas station I don't know why I
don't think yeah I'm looking at his
filmography right now and like he said
he was known for this TV series I guess
he's a sorrow that I've never heard of
before called Gary unmarried that
brilliant saw CBS and it was on the air
from 2008 to 2010 he was the star
I thought it was a movie effort so I'm
like wow we had the leading role in a
movie holy crap but yeah I did see your
actor and I thought it was really really
good but I forgot he was in that too
do you forget he's in there have you
ever seen Jay Mohr think it's like
Jessica Alba like no we're not no we're
not comparing Jay Mohr to Jess I know
how that sounds a weird because when you
hear Jess cowboy you just think hot when
you hear Jay Mohr you're like what no I
just mean I've never seen him given
performer and so I'm like oh that's why
they're an actor so really good
performances make you see that all they
have a passion for the industry and the
ability and the talent
exactly oh okay I never I didn't know
you were such a deep guy Chris well
think about it
I mean why it's like it's the same thing
the same thing if you go to like a
McDonald's or something and they suck at
making your food you're like why are you
working here
you suck at this don't make my food
again or you watch a movie and the
actors just like plotting around on the
screen you're like why are you in movies
you suck at this I'm paying to watch
this movie and then every time they come
on
so with Jessica Alba at least you can be
like okay yeah she's pretty hot but
still you can walk outside and pass a
random girl and you're like oh she's hot
doesn't mean you have to be a
millionaire I'm just saying like earn
earn your money
I mean they're getting paid a crapload
of my vein movies earn it amen
she needs to do her role like where she
gets all dirty and like does not wear
makeup and stuff and it has to be like
all you know some people said she is
good in awake but I've never seen a week
I was just thinking about that movie the
other day on how I need to put it in my
Netflix queue because like I don't know
like it looked really bad but I know
Richard Roeper like really liked he said
it was like a really like good like
campy interesting movie had good plot
twists you know nobody no one saw it and
I thought it looked really done the
story is really dumb but apparently it's
fun movies though probably watch that
sooner or later
should I give my Hayden Christensen fill
there's one thing about Richard Roeper I
mean there are times when I disagree
with him but there there's all these
times when I'm like one of the only
people to love a movie to death and like
all the critics are just like yeah but
he'll love it to stay with me man okay
like same exact thing like whenever
there's like that movie I think that
like no one else likes but me like he
always liked it too like he had shallow
Allen he's fast of that year list I know
and he had signs on his best of the year
list too and several yeah yeah I mean
and Ebert gave that four stars also but
I mean Rover had it on his best of the
year and them also like shutter island'
he gave like an A plus or something and
he also really liked the village that's
true and I like the village except for
the twist but I mean the twist is like
the movie the twist makes the movie you
know I just parts of the twist were dumb
to me that's all but I mean I thought
that movie was directed incredibly well
and I think it's extremely underrated
but and I think actually that's the
movie that broke em night Shyamalan I
think he want kind of nuts after that we
made him break six cents on break